eh ben c'est pas pour me vanter mais le
temps était au tombeau un wiltord y
tombons la concierge est dans l'escalier
le fond de l'air est frais et tout le
reste est à l'avenant la somme
effectuait bien la vérité fait pieux
guéret
la vérité est aguerri à façon de parler
les pâtes commence à guéret dans la
creuse la croiser dans la marche la
marche c'est une nos provinces de
l'ancienne france conclusion la vérité
temps mais c'est pourtant vrai bref y'a
pas de chef de la non mais là il ya eu
un pépin
enfin quoi certains de ses hommes
pourquoi pas ce qu'il y'a plus de saison
depuis qu'accor puis toujours sinon
allemand principe que les explosions
atomiques qui veulent à bon foot n y est
pour rien mais je sais pas non plus
porter mais on prétend pourtant j sort
ou qui sont d d d d imbéciles on n'a pas
attendu la banque n'a même jamais
entendu dire par exemple qui dormait
danemark 6 mais j'ai jamais vu et mais
n'avait jamais assisté personnellement
et l'extension
non non il me semble que si une bombe
avait explosé au-dessus de ma tête je
serais pas en train de causer avec vous
ouais
et vous croyez qu'ils avaient eu que des
hallebardes vous seriez en meilleur état
civil et militaire
vous avez raison de ne pas avoir à tout
à tort ou à raison c'est juste part à
tout prix oui sur la tronche comme vous
dites
eh bien il vaut mieux la plus bas à la
guerre si vous aimez la clusaz savoure
ailleurs et ça vous regarde à bout comme
on dit dans le sud-ouest d'une question
1 l'amener à tous les goûts sont dans la
nature et je dis pas seulement que
j'aime la pluie
ouais mais l'info pour l'agriculture
c'est utile les hallebardes aussi c'est
utile pour l'agriculture ah non non non
pour les suisses en suisse en al-bared
c'est un peu comme un magistrat à coup
ça veut dire d'argent donc on reste
comme d'ailleurs tous les tous les
membres de la magistrature a fait alors
si la tam que les hallebardes leur tombe
du ciel tout rôti soyons pas ridicule en
société je sais danser n'est pas
ridicule mais soyez pas stupide qu'est
ce qui ferait du albar de rôti
mais d'une banda lors d'une conférence
de genève à exemple malins se sont pas
malades
oui mais bien armés et oui comme le
béton pas comme stéphane stephanopoulos
non mallarmé mais à propos des le messie
proposait lui aussi libéré dans ma
lanterne
vous êtes marié nord pourquoi pas le
temps donc pas d'argent pas d'argent pas
de suisse pas de suisse pas de mariage à
la madeleine c'est aussi simple que ça
il n'est pas obligé de vous marier
madeleine à 6 c'est ma paroisse mais
mais vous habitez donc vous avoue leur
pardon jeudi
mais vous avez des dons coup ça vous là
excusez moi alors là j'comprends pas le
bal ou bas où habitez-vous vérité à à la
bastille quartier génial est pourquoi
génial vous n'avez jamais entendu parler
du génie de la bastille à chypre il
s'est repris et vous habitez ou csi ou
déjà votre habitat pardon votre habitat
ou six qu'il était déjà et je suis moi
mais je ne comprends pas le yiddish
colis des yeux vous inviter ou vous va
se dire ah ouais enfin cela ménages
suisses s'est pas trop bruyamment et non
pourquoi
bien qu'un tirage orale baroque nombreux
dont je suis issue et courtois
disciplinés et où travaillent 1 à la
télévision je ne vois pas non si si si
nous occuper des postes importants
pardon un poste d'importance mais on se
fait la pluie et le beau temps c'est moi
qui dessine les plans de la météo des
hallebardes
et oui c'est plus pratique oui
évidemment alors pour le prochain
week-end à collonges un week end de vous
le dire qu'il pensait c'est que ça et
notez bien entendu ou alors voilà les
prévisions annoncées pour celui du 15 ou
alors les prévisions pour le prochain
week end et voilà de nuages ou à pâte
répondent pas très beau a plutôt moche
et depuis thomas cher franchement tarte
avec avec du bois nous avec accumulation
de stratus de cumulo nimbus 2
le vieux mulhouse de cyrus est de 7 8 9
10 et la suite russie serait devancé au
revoir ce média villon puisque plus de
saison très serré et température et ben
voilà sous le patron de ses six sous la
langue contre 7,7 sous tutelle et 38,8
ou le paillasson 39,95
d'ailleurs ils vendent le k way merci
aux un peu sec votre site
en israël ce serait plutôt mal vu et
pourquoi lorsqu'on israël a dit merci
nayppydaw en israël évidemment en egypte
bon et bien sur ce je vais aller manger
un derrière le dos rond mais je ne vous
invite pas pourquoi parce que je vais
voir mon suisse fait par saint-honoré de
la doré nationale qu'est ce que j'ai
fait de mal venu à roissy
[Musique]